I could also write the function
reverseString like this.
Here forwardString is a second name for
the parameter being passed in.
Undoubtedly you're wondering, as i was,
why does this parameter need two names?
stringToReverse is
the local parameter name.
You can see here that it's used locally,
inside the function itself.
This other parameter name forwardString
is the external parameter name, and
it's used externally, in other
words when the function is called.
We'll see more external
parameters in a minute,
when we talk about how
to call functions.
So to update our model,
functions can take this general form.
When you see a name on
the left with no colon,
that's the external parameter name,
and the local parameter name is here.
Now, if you think this is weird,
you're right.
This syntax is very peculiar and
particular to Swift.
And if you think two parameter
names seems excessive,
you would have a good argument.
I won't go into why it's like this, but
it has to do with Swift's
ancestry in Objective C.